radical right-wing media outlet o-a-n
is attempting to resurface from the
bottom of the trash heap
and they are doing so with a so-called
exclusive interview with donald trump
which is really indistinguishable from
north korean propaganda all of the same
tired lies were resuscitated the really
wacky intangible here is the performance
of the interviewer whose name is chanel
rion
we really can't tell this apart
from one of those north korea propaganda
interviews now first check out just the
introduction to the interview and the
first line of the interview it's
desperately sycophantic this doesn't
even count as journalism even in the us
and our journalism standards are really
low really really low take a look at
this president donald j trump left an
indelible mark on u.s politics from the
25th floor of his iconic new york
headquarters one america news sat down
with our 45th president for an exclusive
one-on-one discussion
there he shared with us his forecast his
fears and his hopes for america's
horizon
in the process we witness an
illuminating snapshot into the mind of a
man whose leadership in battles sparked
a movement that forever altered the
course of american history
this is an oan exclusive interview from
new york city new york mr president we
sit here in trump tower many days and
many miles from what many americans
consider an illegitimate biden white
house in the first line of the
introduction she has to mention biden
isn't a legitimate president as many
people see it mr president when you
crowbar illegitimate biden into the
opener you know it's going to be utterly
insane and it got way wackier when trump
started talking here is donald trump
ranting about a so-called third world
election in the united states and
channel rio just chanel rion just can't
help
uh but uh can't help but try
pushing that same thing about oh fraud
any day now we're going to uncover the
fraud and if we can't convince people
that that won't happen again or if we
don't get right down to the bottom of it
and change it
those people aren't going to be there to
vote so the republicans the republicans
are going to have to do something
whether it's mitch mcconnell or kevin
mccarthy
or the leadership locally they have to
do something
there was a an expression that i've
heard that you've heard for
many years the vote counter is far more
important than the politician
or the person running for office and
that was the case in this instance for
the presidential election very sad that
this could happen it was a third world
election well it looks like a lot of
that may well be uncovered very shortly
being uncovered normally we'd see that
and it'd be nice if the papers would
report it
there is so much going on here first of
all on the technical level why is the
audio always terrible with these oan
interviews the amount of room noise
background noise
our tech is a disaster
we never have a background noise issue
like that like i i have no idea what i'm
doing but my interviews never sound like
that how can oan in an interview with
the president
not make it sound reasonable
what i'm realizing is that an interview
with a real anchor or journalist and
trump
it's already wacky
just because of the things that donald
trump says but at least when there's a
sort of real interviewer the questions
can sometimes get back on track there
can sometimes be an attempt to hold
donald trump accountable for what he's
saying
what chanel rion from oan is doing is
participating in the shared delusions
with donald trump trump says crazy stuff
about fraud and instead of asking for
receipts she asks she adds to it by
saying oh yeah any day now we're going
to uncover the fraud here's another
piece of this in which donald trump
again claims to have blockbuster
technology coming this is great because
for months he touted a new digital
communication social media platform that
he was going to be launching and instead
he just launched a blog it's just like
blogspot technology installed on his
website and now again he's teasing he
has something really big coming so we
had
a couple of hundred million people
and the problem is
a lot of these platforms you can't put
that many people on it just doesn't work
if they explode if you put 500 000 on
it's like a lot
and they can't handle it
and the technology just isn't there
right now for that but the technology is
coming very rapidly and we're working on
something that i think will be a
blockbuster when it happens it's going
to be something that's going to be
special but you know
i've been offered companies for almost
nothing big chunks of companies that
have platforms the problem is they can't
hold the people yeah the platforms out
there just can't handle the amount of
people that want to follow trump what
facebook can't hold trump's audience
twitter can't hold trump's audience
youtube can't hold it these are
delusions of the highest level and
chanel rion is just helping him along
and then we get to the point of the
interview
where trump again claims the election
results aren't possible he just doesn't
believe that he lost so obviously it
must be fraud what people want to talk
about is it all comes down to what
happened in the election
because you look at georgia
georgia was fantastic
what happened to all those votes
what happened to all those people that
was standing on the line
wearing red hats
and wearing all sorts of things that
what happened and then you look at
michigan and you look at
how do you win ohio in a record in
florida in a record in south carolina in
a record in iowa and a record
and then you lose michigan
and you lose pennsylvania
we were up at 10 30 in the evening by so
much in pennsylvania it wasn't doable
unless something crooked happened it is
abundantly clear that he will never move
past this he still hasn't accepted that
he lost the popular vote in 2016. he
will never admit that he lost in 2020
and it's the same talking points now six
months out from the election we were
leading at 10 p.m and suddenly there
were these massive dumps of ballots and
then we were losing
it's over and over and over again the
same talking point let's look at just
one more clip and then we'll move on
trump asked about joe biden on china
what was biden's first mistake here we
go see if you can understand this china
what was biden's first mistake
well i think he made many mistakes
number one he's shown such weakness you
know they have planes flying over taiwan
now
they never had this you know they never
had these problems he wouldn't have had
this problem in israel
they didn't shoot rockets when i was
there they were shooting thousands of
rockets into israel that wouldn't have
happened with me well within four years
your administration brokered historic
peace deals in the middle east and
within four months the biden
administration essentially has is
overseeing a war just total fantasy
world views of how things work biden
showed weakness
but then he says something about israel
instead the question was about china
now i do think there are people
who see interviews like this
and they do think trump has an idea what
he's talking about that's the really
scary part
and we know
that that's the case
because 74 million people voted for the
guy but it's really something else how
vapid and meaningless what he says is
and having a reporter help him along as
chanel rion did in this it's very dark
for what it portends about journalism in
the united states if you can even really
still call this journalism and i don't
think you can
let me know what you think very
depressing and bizarre interview
one of our sponsors is vincero watches
giving you 15 off a high quality
wristwatch is the perfect way to elevate
your style own at least one watch that
makes you feel great when you put it on
you can often see me wearing my ventura
watch on the show
mine is the gunmetal vessel model i'm a
big fan of the metallic look of the face
of the watch i like the silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price anywhere else when you
put it on you know you got more than you
paid for vincero believes in crafting
super quality watches from high-end
materials but selling them at fair
prices which is why they have over
twenty six thousand five star reviews
and they stand behind every watch they
make with a one-year return policy and
five-year warranty
they'll give you 15 percent off
everything in their store and free
shipping at davidpakman.com
watch use the coupon code pacman